fine words for the un dirtier deeds
back home a brand new coal power station
under construction in china's rust belt
this is heilongjiang province
on the edge of siberia and the builders
are working hard on a friday evening
at a time when the rest of the world is
drawing away from coal
the exhaust tower proudly bears the year
of its construction
china is apparently digging in for
decades here in the far
north eastern corner of china coal power
has been linked to economic development
and that's still the case today with
that plant going up
but for china to meet its pledge it's
going to have to somehow
break that chain china's leader xi
jinping pledged to the u.n
that the country would reach peak
emissions in less than a decade
and be carbon neutral by 2060. those are
the words
but these are the actions in the first
half of 2020 alone
china has approved more coal power
projects than it did in the previous two
years combined
according to global energy monitor a u.s
ngo
and postcovid china is spending three
times as much on carbon intensive
projects than green ones
according to one analysis but climate
change is just as urgent here as it is
around the world
this summer china was hit by the worst
flooding in decades
hundreds died and some chinese experts
say climate change is partly to blame
in harbin the capital of heilongjiang
they are still preparing flood defenses
into september the city was spared the
worst
but locals know how big the problem is
[Music]
is one of china's most famous
environmentalists uh
you know we are concerned about uh the
all this new kind of coal
uh projects uh being uh authorized
because
you know this may uh let
lead into some sort of a locked in type
of uh
scenario and the whole situation is
hanging in the balance you know we're at
some sort of crossroads
china has invested more in renewable
energy than any other country
the scale of that can be hard to
comprehend
but to meet the 2060 pledge it needs to
kick its dependence on coal
and that simply is not happening in
heilongjiang
the builders will be back at work
tomorrow tom cheshire sky news
north east china